quartier bon dont un 3 3 ans je me suis
encore trop bas côté
vous avez là quatre bassines 4 et plus
et 50 kg des patates dans lequel on des
pommes de terre je vous ai convoqué pour
éplucher les pommes de terre parce que
la machine est en panne
comment il n'ya pas d'ouvriers pour le
faire question pourquoi je vous ai comme
bouquet toi eh bien je pense que pour
que mes amis de neuilly et moi même nous
libérions c'est féculents de leur
enveloppe charnelle bombardements mais
plus chez pas 4 violent j'avais compris
aller au travail ex à son ex as autant
de têtes ça te dérange pas non je
rejoins de mes copains merci bien
comment s'y prendre quand tu prends un
impact dans une main les plus réputés
plus bas j'aurais préféré peluches et
des douces je pense qu'ici est plus
simple espace et de prendre le féculent
de port une extrémité et avec le couteau
d'abord c'est un mouvement rotatif afin
d'obtenir une seule solution gagne un
temps considérable s'est traduit bien la
quelle frange la moins ça
beyani si ma mère savait que travaillant
au noir
à quoi
j'ai entendu une phrase les cadets vous
une a dit
j'ai rien vu lance azzurri n'ont pas
roulé
là tu as une tête qui respire le
masochisme m'expliquer comment on
épluche les pattes intitulant j'allais
vite à peine de moitié si tu es pleuvait
que les autres allez laissez moi une
belle chimie
parce que c'est toi c'est dur je ne
l'avais pour le dire c'était moi je fais
tu sais l'armée avant tout c'est la
justice oui c'est faux fumer dans les
bars
merci bouger leur ego je ne donnais pas
ils vont chanter vous avez déjà tiré oui
avec marie-chantal aurais je parle de
chasse ah oui on va l'année dernière de
son parti en safari avec papa tels que
vous me voyez j'ai chassé l'éléphant
bien moi je n'ai passé que le frein et
bien moi dernièrement
figurez vous que j'ai chassé la bonne
ben moi j'ai tiré la chasse
à
pardon monsieur excusez-moi sergent puis
je vous posais une question indiscrète
vous ne seriez pas dacia
pourquoi territoire parce que je suis
alsacienne d'ilan je sais pas qui tu es
mais je te soupçonne doigts oui je suis
de strasbourg
j'aurais plutôt cru que mes la forêt
noire et les quatre ans jouit boudent
ils voudront vous vivement la sorbonne
28 ans quelles facs toi de moi j'étais à
sciences po nous allons finir sur ce
coup de tête et ben moi j'ai raté les ma
maman était folle et toi tu étais de
tuer de quelle région
je suis 100 de la france oui mais
d'accord mais dans quelles facs
c'est dans le centre de la france de
quelles facs je suis belle et je suis
mais avant je vous parle plus quand tu
vas pas te fâcher pour serge en dit long
et puis quand j'ai vu ça oui il a une
simca 1000 avec la queue dutil aussi
fondamentale et pourquoi vous dites que
le sergent et à kung fu dire ce qui est
c'est pas une lumière mais c'est pas de
sa faute et sont détenus toute façon il
est pas content c'est un triple
d'accord vous et vous tu es bon boulot
vous côtoyez de danger allez on a
produit du jeu et ben vous voyez les
gars il est passé des graisses que salma
cake
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pour toi de l'ag